welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
vos and the Marvel Cinematic Universe
just extended forward even further into
the future with a third ant-man film
confirmed for release in 2022 Paul Rudd
returning the Scott Lang Michael Douglas
returning this Hank Pym Peyton Reed
returning to direct and hopefully Lewis
returning to narrate the whole movie
because that would be awesome as we saw
in Avengers in games Scott Lang's
experiences in the quantum realm proved
to be crucial to the Avengers victory
and there's still so much about the
quantum realm that week to go from
hidden cities in the background to Clues
pointing to human mutation and evolution
and yes the continued existence of
vortexes that enable time travel
how will ant-man 3 explore these
mysteries along with the loose threat of
an older Cassandra Lang to set up the
next generation of Avengers I will
discuss these questions in this episode
of inside Marvel
[Music]
okay let us first explain this new
Marvel film timeline 2021 will be a
packed here for the MCU with shang-chi
and the legends of the ten rings coming
February 2021 followed by Wanda Bishan
coming on Disney Plus and spring 2021
then Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness in May 2021 the Loki Disney Plus
series in that spring spider-man 3
coming that July the Marvel animated
what-if series on Disney Plus in that
summer the Hawkeye Disney Plus series in
fall and then Thor 11 Thunder finishing
2021 in November as I said packed
that brings us to 2022 which we
previously have heard will release Black
Panther 2 in May 20-22 and this ant-man
3 film according to Michael Douglas is
scheduled to begin production in January
2021 which could put it on track for
Marvel's release date of February 18 20
22 but more realistically with all of
its visual effects more likely release
date would be July 29 2022 meanwhile
that February date could be the idea
release date for the marshal Ollie Blade
reboot but why is this timeline so
important well note that this third
ant-man film will come after the Wanda
vision and multiverse of madness events
after the third spider-man film after
the Hawkeye series which is cast Hailee
Steinfeld is Kate Bishop and after the
five year blip period of Avengers in
game
Cassie Lang is now an older teenager
played by Emma Furman essentially the
MCU is Lane much of the groundwork to
establish the next generation of the
Avengers do carry the torch the Young
Avengers so quick summary on The Young
Avengers from the Marvel Comics first
introduced following the Avengers
disassembled storyline in 2005 The Young
Avengers featured iron lad Nathaniel
Richards a descendant of Reed Richards
Hulk lean son of a Kree and a scroll
Patriot grandson of the one-time cap
Isiah Bradley Wiccan reincarnated son of
Scarlet Witch and vision Hawkeye Kate
Bishop and Cassandra Lang carrying her
father's legacy now as this size
changing hero stature
Nathaniel Richards has an Iron Man like
suit in which he uploads the remnants of
visions operating system where he
discovers a failsafe plan to rebuild the
Avengers should the adult Avengers ever
be defeated
Nathaniel forms this group to take on
Kang the Conqueror a time-traveling
villain who is for its a future version
of Nathaniel Richards yeah it's pretty
great huh and you can definitely
the dots of the upcoming MCU titles and
see how they could absolutely be in the
process of assembly and something
similar to this Young Avengers team and
ant-man the wasp Cassie Lange when she
was younger
hinted at her desire to follow in her
father's footsteps so maybe you just
need some watching back like a partner
do I do didn't you think me you I'd be a
great partner peanut hmm it would be
awesome and now that Cassandra is a bit
older and presumably a bit more
coordinated yeah cuz angeling really
could be awesome as stature and by this
time we will also have Hailee Steinfeld
as a young Hawk I keep Bishop checked
check now Wiccan comes about after the
Scarlet Witch house of M event something
I have a feeling the Wanda vision series
could adapt since house of M is the
best-known Scarlet Witch story and if
they're making a Wanda Maximoff series
they'd be crazy not to bring it in in
some form Wanda vision could end with
the reveal of mutants in the MCU which
could include her son Wiccan someone
Wanda manifested from her mind along
with Wiccans sister speed before having
another mental breakdown and declaring
mutants in this case wanted could wish
for mutants in order to better arm and
protect earth against future threats but
what about iron lad could this character
already exist in the MCU I think it's
possible
you've been looking closely but before I
continue thank you to manscape for
sponsoring this episode
manscape comm is the only men's brand
dedicated to below the waist grooming
and hygiene they created world's first
manscaping kit that makes the process
safe and easy their perfect package 2.0
kit features the lawnmower 2.0 a
waterproof cordless electric manscaping
trimmer with proprietary skin-safe
technology meaning no Nicks and no snags
and most importantly no more painful
anxiety that you're gonna do to your
nuts what Thor did to Thanos both when
he didn't go for the head and when he
did yep
the perfect package 2.0 kit also comes
with several liquid formulations to
round out your manscaping routine
including the crop preserver anti
shaping ball deodorant and the crop
revive a refreshing spray which actually
goes on your van just kidding it also
goes on your balls look if he put
deodorant on the rest of you you gotta
keep fresh Scott Lang's favorite body
parts 65
huge 65 if you to our finish comparing
sizes what you seen the perfect package
2.0 kick gives you your biggest bang for
your buck and the biggest church anchor
here as a subscriber you will get 25%
off your order instantly and a new
replacement blade every three months and
for a limited time not one but two free
gifts the shed travel bag love this
thing and performance anti chafing man's
good boxer briefs wearing these babies
you'll head out the door just slide and
shimmy and just like Scotland get 20%
off plus free shipping from your perfect
package 2.0 purchase when he use the
promo code Rock 20 and manscaped calm
okay back to someone who probably
doesn't have to worry so much about body
scaping yet iron lad who is this guy in
the MCU well some of specula that iron
lad could have been established in
characters like Harley keiner who did
randomly appear at Tony Stark's funeral
and endgame or perhaps Tony Stark's
daughter Morgan Stark both these
characters seem like potential future
engineers with very bright futures but a
reminder that spider-man far from home
included a few potentially big nods to
the Fantastic Four joining the MCU both
in its final scene
Peter glided through the newly
constructed atrium of Avengers tower
implying new occupants perhaps Reed
Richards transforming the tower into the
Baxter building and on the street level
behind Peter and MJ was that sign we
can't wait to show you what comes next
one two three question mark usually for
is what comes next in that sequence but
good before more Bradley to just these
four but even so the Fantastic Four
arriving in phase four just to perfect
so I think the third spider-man film
could be the ideal opportunity to
introduce characters from Marvel's first
family could be Reed Richards or his
descendants Nathaniel Richards and if
the MCU does plan to go full Young
Avengers the groundwork is also
completed to bring in Kang the Conqueror
again the quantum realm remains quite
the land of mystery Janet Van Dyne
explained her survival to Hank Pym and
most cryptic words the adaptation is
part of it but some of it is evolution
is out of that subatomic layer they
passed an Easter Egg that Peyton Reed
hid in the background imagery a quantum
realm city suggesting some form of
civilization on that level now we have
discussed before how the city could be
the kind of subatomic civilization
introduced in the early Fantastic Four
comics
microworld also described a subatomic ax
a place where Doctor Doom while trying
to shrink the Fantastic Four that
himself shrinking into oblivion but
actually we found out later he became
ruler of this micro world and used it to
mountains come back against the
Fantastic Four the MCU could use this
quantum realm city to similarly
establish a new villain as its ruler but
since the quantum realm of the cinematic
universe contains time vortexes it would
be the perfect place to establish a
time-traveling villain Kang the
Conqueror future version of the young
Nathaniel Richards Peter Parker perhaps
meets in his next film perhaps the way
Scott Lang without Tony Stark's
time-traveling navigation device
chaotically grew older and younger when
trying to explore the quantum realms
time vortexes that could be how Kang the
Conqueror ends up the way he does look I
know it almost sounds crazy but it's got
to make a lot more sense coming out of
Janet Van Dyne mouth as she explains the
weird subatomic city and it's weird
mayor that she lived thirty years with -
Cassandra Lang and ant-man 3 aka
ant-man and stature maybe there's a
better name there anyway how do you
think the third ant-man film will set up
the MCS future comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at a vas and follow me rock
stars and social media at rockstars and
subscribe to this YouTube channel to
join us as we go deep in deeper inside
Marvel so deep were renting an apartment
downtown QR
[Music]